so sometimes i'll say kind of
metaphorically that uh trump rallies and
trump events are sort of like these
circus ten evangelical churches but we
we don't literally mean that
but trump's rally in selma north
carolina over the weekend actually
really seemed like one
madison cothorn the radical republican
trumpist congressman who is in a
wheelchair he's paralyzed i guess it's
from the waist down from a car accident
he did
a sort of reenactment of the type of
scene you would normally see like in an
evangelical faith healing church
where he performed a miracle and stood
up using his arms holding himself up on
on a walker type thing with the help of
two people and and metal braces on his
on his legs i believe
and
this is
it's horrible on so many levels and i'm
going to talk about it so let's i'm
going to play the clip for you if you're
only listening what i'm gonna i'll it's
important that i describe that what's
going on is
he is performing a miracle by standing
despite being paralyzed from the waist
down to just look at this seven dollars
a gallon
my friends this country can change very
quickly
and it may seem impossible people tell
me that it's impossible to change the
direction of our country
that it's impossible to root out the
corruption in our government
here he goes
[Applause]
[Music]
so they bring out a walker and then two
people kind of stand them up
this is a miracle that he's
performing there he is
well my friends god spared my life he
has given me the strength to stand
before you today so do not lecture me on
what is impossible
my fellow patriots americans are in the
business of doing the impossible because
with god all things are possible
yeah
so listen first of all of course no
disrespect to his physical condition
whatsoever i wish he had never gotten
into that car accident i wish he had
full use of his legs of course of course
of course i would never
ridicule anyone for
i mean he he has a terrible medical
condition it's horrible okay but what
are the issues here
first of all
it's not like he stood up and walked
around and so even this framing of with
god anything is possible well why didn't
god keep you out of the accident
why didn't god give you the ability to
walk rather than just
standing in this way right i mean it's
it's no disrespect to him it's great
that he can stand on the strength of his
arms that's a beautiful thing that's
better than not being able to do it but
why is it if you're invoking that god
did these things why wouldn't god have
spared you from the accident or from the
paralysis or it it just doesn't make any
sense these are indefeasible comments
first of all secondly um fdr used to do
this okay fdr
did this without fanfare
he didn't say it's god's work fdr didn't
weaponize
his physical problem
to try to
sucker people into supporting anything
in particular fdr had actual policy
ideas and that's part of it it's sad
that it works with this crowd
and um it
you know it's also not super surprising
that there's this palpable lack of
authentic spirituality that pervades the
republican party it performative
charlatanism and that's what we saw here
from madison cothorn you don't see this
and go that is some authentic
spirituality you go that's that's like
the type of act you would expect at a
faith healing church and it is classic
cult stuff i may do a deeper dive into
this later this week or next week there
is a book called thought reform and the
psychology of totalism a study of
brainwashing in china it's written by
robert j lifton
this is a fantastic book
and it talks about the different
elements
for
brainwashing people what is sometimes
called thought reform and one of the
items on the list is what's called
mystical manipulation
the manipulation of experiences that
appears spontaneous
but it's actually planned and
orchestrated by the group or its leaders
to demonstrate divine authority
spiritual advancement exceptional talent
or insight that sets the leader apart
from humanity and allows a
reinterpretation of historical event
scripture and other experiences that is
exactly what madison cawthorne is doing
here he's doing this mystical
manipulation where he's able to rise up
and stand despite being paralyzed
kawthorne also does number three number
three is a demand for purity the world
is viewed as black and white
everybody is exhorted to conform to the
ideology of the group and to strive for
perspective perfection and they use
guilt and shame to control people his
recent stuff with the orgies and the
cocaine he presents himself as he's pure
he's been told that the orgies and the
cocaine go on he doesn't participate in
it he's the pure one
um sacred science is another item from
the list of criteria for thought reform
the group's doctrine or ideology is
considered to be the ultimate truth
beyond questioning and dispute truth is
not found outside the group the leader
as the spokesperson for god or humanity
is likewise above criticism this is more
general to trumpism trump literally has
said
you don't believe what you're seeing
don't believe what you're hearing i will
tell you what's really going on i will
give you the truth
and then lastly from this list loading
the language the group interprets or
uses words and phrases in new ways so
that often the outside world doesn't
understand
this includes thought-terminating
cliches which serve to alter members
thought process to conform the group's
way of thinking they do that all the
time uh for example fake news that's a
thought-terminating cliche
it's not it's not really fake news it's
just news you disagree with
it's reporting that's not good for you
that's fake news that's it or hey you
know what that was incredibly
insensitive and discriminatory what
you're oh you're woke
that's another thought-terminating
cliche
this is incredible how closely their
behavior conforms to these brainwashing
techniques and we will talk about that
more one of our sponsors is blinkist
who's been supporting the david pakman
show longer than any other sponsor
blinkist is the app that lets you listen
to or read an entire non-fiction book in
just 15 minutes blinkist is the way to
absorb those books you can't make time
for blinkist takes top non-fiction
titles pulls out the book's key
takeaways and insights and gives it to
you in the form of a text or audio
explainer that you can consume in 15
minutes with blinkist now you actually
do have time to learn about all the
things you've been wanting to tackle on
the blinkist app i just listened to this
is your mind on plants by the great
michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below